yeah Kelly and Theo have a unique
relationship as a sufferer of narcolepsy
Kelly falls asleep without warning it
can strike wherever and whenever
but luckily Theo is never far from her
side well that's part of Theo's training
Kelly often puts him through his paces
and we're gonna see what that looks like
right now okay Theo is a specially
trained medical detection dog as soon as
he senses that Kelly is having a turn
he's on hand to look after her
beforethey I didn't go home ever with
Theo if I go out shopping just me and
him
if I fall he'll immediately now a note
and bark till I wake up and then other
people will quite often oh stop and
watch and they'll say to me oh I didn't
want to disturb you because he looked
like he knew what he was doing
Theo was trained to smell the chemical
changes that occur in Kelly's body by
this charity in Milton Keynes dozens of
dogs are trained to smell various
diseases here Daisy is sniffing out the
sample that contains bladder cancer her
detection rate is 93 percent and it's
these results that are turning heads in
the medical world taken sometimes get
over the skepticism but this is an
evidence-based work we've published a
number of medical journals and it's now
proof that that disease does have this
odor and therefore dogs can be used in a
whole variety of ways to warn us when
these odors occur consultants are now
sending samples in for tests on a weekly
basis no Claire hopes that dogs will
become a normal part of disease
detection and patient assistance how
we've missed this for so long the dogs
that have been living around it can do
this it's quite incredible
it's a new non-invasive way of keeping
people safe
and of detecting human disease there are
around 31,000 not Excel e in the country
her family says dogs like Theo could
make a big difference to many other
people there's probably people sitting
at home now
who think like she did at one point when
my life's not going to go anywhere and
now I say she works she goes to college
she does everything so it would be great
other people would so it'd be nice for
other people to see how well she's doing
to give them the encouragement as well
using dogs in this way is still a
relatively new practice
but for Kelly it's undoubtedly changed
her life
Joe tidy Sky News